this is my friend Jordan mm-hmm there
are some specific laws governing the
production of Chianti and Chianti
Classico for example Chianti needs to be
at least 70% Sangiovese and then I heard
in the Kohli Sanusi it has to be 75% and
in chianti classico needs to be 1807 and
i and we're kind of bordering all three
of those places so my first question is
what is the minimum required percentage
of Sangiovese in this wine he's betting
going hmm we can memorize so tonight do
we have 100 percentage of slides yes
that's a choice but the minimum
requirement high law is either 70 75 or
80% depending on which region that you
are in exactly excuse me you look bored
no but I saw to your soul anyway what's
your question I can remember the
percentages of what a hundred percent
Sangiovese is present in this wine okay
well that solves that mystery call the
cops and wrap this thing up
what do you think it's a hotline
it's a hotline you know that expression
a hot one yeah let me not feel like I'm
awesome which way I'm feeling of
sexiness but you're alone in the woods
that's right you don't feel sexy when
you're alone not the woods what about
the woods is unsexy to you it's the
woods you ever take a look at the the
dry soil of Chianti I mean you when you
drink this wine you feel connected to
that dirt dirt is your turn up can you
imagine being in the woods naked covered
in dirt it's simply something very
primal about very sexual are you okay to
proceed yeah this is completely
different right there you know I'm
smelling right now what's that a frog
this one I'm getting more air here I'm
getting air and then I'm getting Earth
Wind and Fire
clean glasses would be good again she's
trying to escape look at this purpose
look at this now okay salad you don't
use your nose and then say look at this
speech so to be honest with you a lot of
people like drinking a glass of wine as
an aperitivo I always like only wine
with food because to me wine is not a
drink wine is a food and wine is as much
of food as like the salt that goes on
the steak they all complement one
another there's no steak without wine
there's no line without steak they're
interdependent their symbiotic it's like
a parasite and its host organism
so I have to leave with him away from
this that's probably a nice feeling for
you yeah I'm taking him with me
you